[Musique]
on
je mens
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre les travaux
du sénat cet après midi les sénateurs
auditionnent le secrétaire d'état aux
transports jean baptiste djebbari dans
le cadre de la commission d' enquête sur
la privatisation des autoroutes cette
commission s'intéresse à ces concessions
autoroutières parfois accusés de faire
des profits juteux sur le dos des
automobilistes je vous laisse écouter
cette audition rentable à l'époque les
les sections interurbaines cela a eu le
mérite indéniable d'aménager ou de
soutenir l'aménagement du territoire et
on peut assez facilement s'en convaincre
quand on regarde la carte de l'année 60
par exemple à la carte du milieu des
années 90 et je crois que ça a participé
sur le plan de l'aménagement du
territoire à soutenir la vitalité et la
connectivité d'un certain nombre de
territoires d'un grand massif central et
est ailleurs et de fait se résout devenu
important puisque de 80 km au moment de
sa création donc l'année 1955 il est
passé à peu près 1500 km en 1970 et il
compte aujourd'hui un peu plus de 9000
km 9 mille 100 km ce qui fait de ce
réseau un réseau quasiment comparable au
réseau nous concéder qui compte
aujourd'hui à peu près douze mille
kilomètres alors peut-être pour retenir
que deux dates on peut retenir
évidemment la date de 2006 qui fut un
tournant majeur celui de la
privatisation des concessions on peut
certainement de ce point de vue là et ça
a été dit par d'autres s'interroger sur
le fait que le changement d'actionnaire
n'est pas été exécutée sans revoir les
modalités du contrat et notamment la loi
tarifaire qui en fait est la pomme de
discorde depuis depuis ce moment là qui
a donné lieu à beaucoup d'interactions
beaucoup d'interrogations beaucoup de
d'informations parfois beaucoup de
contres de contre vérités et qui a eu le
défaut en tout cas d' altérer la
confiance des élus d'une partie de
l'opinion sur la gestion de l'état d'une
part et sur le déséquilibre supposée
entre l'état et les sociétés
concessionnaires
le deuxième moment important de mon
point de vue c'est l'année 2015 et le
protocole de 2015 qui a permis à la fois
de de solder les litiges et différends
les tiges qui s'exerçait ce moment là
et de tirer profit d'un certain nombre
de recommandations de la cour des compte
d'autorités de la concurrence de la
commission européenne
et je crois que les mesures qui ont été
prises ont permis pour le faire
différemment il ya vraiment un avant et
un après 2015 avec non seulement
l'autorité de régulation des transports
l'art à faire à l'époque devenu auto
régulation des transports qui a
compétence pour donner les avis qu'ils
sont importants et qui ont été mises en
oeuvre en 2018 par exemple avec la
capacité d'instaurer une clause de
plafonnement des surprofits pour la
rentabilité des avenants et puis
différentes contributions qui sont venus
en quelque sorte préfigurer ce que
seront les autoroutes de demain avec la
contribution volontaire des sociétés
concessionnaires essentiellement versé à
lafitte pour financer les transports
collectifs et puis la mise en place de
mesures commerciales pour favoriser à la
fois les publics les plus fragiles les
jeunes les étudiants et puis des modes
de transport plus vertueux je pense
notamment aux aménagements qui ont été
faits à l'époque en faveur du
covoiturage
si j'en viens au présent peut-être en
quelques mots dire d'abord que nous
vivons sous l' empire finalement du
modèle mis à jour en 2015 et qui a déjà
porté ses fruits puisque l'avenant au
pays en 2018
c'est directement éclairé de la vie de
la rt notamment s'agissant du taux de
rentabilité et que nous avons par là
même démontré je crois à l'intérêt
d'avoir un régulateur fort sur ces
sujets nous avons aussi des enjeux très
contemporain très actuelles liées à la
transition écologique
vous les connaissez c'est notamment
l'implantation des bornes électriques
qui sont particulièrement importantes
pour permettre l'itinérance et ça fait
assez largement écho d'ailleurs au plan
de soutien à l'industrie automobile qui
en avait bien besoin de héros bien tout
ça tout ça est lié tout ce soutien
évidemment aussi des besoins
d'investissements pour les voies
réservées pour permettre de faire
davantage de transports collectifs sur
les autoroutes et de ce fait nous sommes
face à un besoin d'investissements
nouveaux et d'investissement qui sont
importants sur le plan financier nous
avons évidemment l'obligation que le
modèle actuel est le modèle le futur
soit acceptable du point du non
seulement de l'usagé et du contribuable
mais j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
alors pour l'avenir peut-être d'abord
dire que vous savez que les principales
concessions les concessions historiques
arrive à échéance entre 2031 et 2036 que
le droit européen pose un certain nombre
de conditions sur la perception des
péages et je pense que dans cette
perspective-là quelques questions ont
finalement assez basique se pose mais
qui ne sont pas des questions faciles
la première question c'est de savoir si
on veut gérer opérationnellement ou la
façon dont on veut gérer
opérationnellement notre réseau
autoroutier autrement dit veux-t-on une
gestion unitaire de l'ensemble du réseau
j'ai rappelé les grandes masses 1,9 mais
km de réseaux concédés 9000 kilomètres
de résoudre nos concédé qu'on pourrait
appeler résout d'aménagement du
territoire ou veux-t-on préserver
finalement une gestion différenciée
entre d'une part un réseau rapide est
payant et on pourra peut-être revenir
sur la question des 110 km heure un
réseau rapide et pillon puis un réseau
d'aménagement du territoire gratuits
financés par la puissance publique est
de ce fait si ce deuxième modèle perdure
veux ton ou doit-on avoir recours en
tout ou partie à des opérateurs privés
la deuxième question qui me paraît
importante c'est qu'ils financent ce
modèle veux-t-on un modèle intégralement
financée par l'état c'est le cas par
exemple en espagne en tout cas
nouvellement en espagne puisque puisque
je crois que la fin des concessions a
pris a pris effet au 1er janvier 2020
l'état financera pas été assez
évidemment le financement par l'impôt et
donc lille finit par là par le
contribuable
et si oui comment sécuriser ses
ressources dans des contextes où la
régulation budgétaire est une réalité
administrative annuel ou a contrario
vote ont préservé un modèle où
finalement ses luges et l'usagé pardon
qui est le payeur et peut-être même
souhaiterait ton dans cette hypothèse
aller vers une plus grande contribution
de ceux qui polluent polluent le plus
aujourd'hui ou dans l'avenir
puis la troisième question qui me paraît
importante c'est de savoir ce qu'on veut
faire de maintenant à l'échéance 2030 et
1 2036 pour prendre ses premières
chances importantes
on peut évidemment ne rien faire ne pas
toucher aux contrats tels qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui
parce qu'on considérait que ces contrats
sont des objets positif politique pardon
un peu trop directif on peut les révisés
en tenant compte des améliorations de
2015 y compris parce que dans les
contrats qui existent aujourd'hui et il
ya des investissements qui n'ont
certainement plus la même pertinence
qu'auparavant je pense notamment à des
élargissements de voies autoroutières à
deux fois trois voies ou deux fois 4
voies qui sont des investissements
anciens qui peut-être ne raisonne pas
forcément avec les la nature des
investissements que j'ai pu citer
auparavant et puis le chapeau de ces
différentes questions c'est comment
rendons ce modèle acceptable parce
qu'évidemment ces sujets là peuvent
susciter l'émoi houle enthousiasme
notamment quand on en débat localement
et j'ai eu à vivre cette expérience très
personnelle sur le projet de tour de
concède entre limoges et poté mais si
vous voulez bien j'ai merdé peut-être au
cours des questions et il me semble que
ce sujet c'est un sujet de de
consentement d'acceptabilité
d'acceptabilité locales et mon
expérience à la fois de députés et le
secrétaire d'état en charge des
transports me laisse à penser que la
vraie clé c'est la perception ou la
conviction que ces projets se font par
qu'ils ont une utilité socio économique
local
autrement dit tous les grands projets
qui ont achoppé ces dernières années je
pense à l'europe à city à notre dame des
landes sont des projets qui ont fini par
ne plus faire sens pour les populations
qui ne voyaient pas ou qui ne percevait
pas l'utilité socio-économique qu'il
pourrait en retirer pour eux mêmes et je
pense que de ce point de vue là les
projets d'infrastructure présente les
mêmes caractéristiques
donc de toutes ces questions peuvent
découler des modèles très différents
d'un au bio évidemment je jamais qu'une
fine et un projet de l'infrastructure
n'est n'est qu'un n'est pas une fin en
soi c'est un projet qui répond aux
besoins de la société et ses besoins
évidemment évolué je crois que la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
une des illustrations de ces évolutions
sociétales
mais que cela me semble constituer
évidemment et collectivement un très bel
objet de débat politique
voilà pour ce propos liminaire merci
monsieur le ministre pour ses propos et
vous avez effectivement bien posé toutes
les problématiques que
la commission soulève à travers les
différentes auditions
monsieur le rapporteur manche à vincent
ministre c'est pas pour contredire le
président mais c'est vrai qu'il ya aussi
quelques éléments complémentaires sur
lesquels on se penche mais que vous
n'avez pas forcément abordé dans ses
propos liminaires mais il était assez
court et je vous en remercie
/
donc alors vous avez vous avez pris des
positions quand vous étiez députés 1 sur
la création d'une société à capitaux
publics pour reprendre en gestion les
concessions d'autoroutes historique 1
est-ce que vous restez toujours sur
cette ligne là ce que c'est toujours une
idée que vous avez en tête
est ce qu'elle se fondait sur simplement
une conviction ou est-ce que ceux fondés
sur un certain nombre d'études ou
d'éléments financiers que sur lesquels
vous aviez pu travailler
donc est ce que c'est
c'est un sujet que vous pouvez aborder
dans les discussions interministérielles
au sein du gouvernement où est-ce que ça
reste ça reste dans dans les archives de
l'assemblée nationale et des positions
prises par le député jean baptiste
djebbari sur le sur la rt vous avez dit
fort justement est ce qu'on entend
depuis un petit moment nous dans cette
commission denquête c'est qu'il ya un
avant et un après 2015 carrément d'une
façon générale à la fois dans le suivi
et dans l'organisation de ce suivi des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
qui trouve d'ailleurs que le suivi est
peut-être un peu trop trop stricte et
trop régulier trop fréquent est trop
trop sais pas quoi en tout cas et trouve
que que déséquilibre se fait plutôt en
faveur de l'état et
et puis aussi sur le plan
législatif aussi un et puisqu'il ya eu
comme des améliorations apportées
notamment le fait que les prorogations
de contrats doivent passer par
l'autorisation du parlement
ce qui me semble aussi quand même une
bonne chose de ce point de vue là est-ce
que sur ces aspects là est-ce que vous
avez vous pensez qu'il peut y avoir
encore des améliorations apportées à la
fois peut-être dans l'est dans les
missions les fonctions qu'elle est oui
l'émission de la rt la façon d'aborder
son contrôle son avis la prise en compte
de ces avis donc ça m'intéresse d'avoir
votre point de vue sur ce sujet et puis
effectivement est-ce que bessard joue un
petit peu après la question est ce que
finalement vous penser aujourd'hui que
il faut mieux en étant assez strict dans
le contrôle comme doit l'être l'état à
chaque fois qu'on délègue ou pour
confier une mission au secteur privé il
me semble normal que kylie à un contrôle
de strictes qu'ils soient réalisés
et est ce que est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils fois les donc au bout des
concessions actuelles et comment
préparer la suite
ce que bien pour la série donc
rapporteur bon pour indiquer que éric
bocquet monsieur jacques 15 sont
inscrits pour poser leurs questions
je vais d'abord vous demander de
répondre aux premières questions de
notre rapporteur la parole monsieur
monsieur prix énorme sur la porte à
beaucoup de questions je vais essayer
d'y répondre de façon chronologique
j'ai la volonté de croire que je suis un
homme de constance et que tout est
public et donc je ne renie rien des
propos que j'avais pu tenir à l'époque
mais qui étaient des propos qui visaient
deux éléments différents y avait d'une
part le financement de la louve mobilité
avec un dispositif que je vais expliquer
maintenant et qui s'inspirait très
largement d'ailleurs de discussion que
j'avais pu avoir avec terry dallas qui
est le patron de la société du grand
paris et qui avait mené des travaux sur
ce qu'on appelait la contribution de
mobilité durable qui avait une
production de l'institut de gestion
déléguée
et puis ce que j'ai expliqué mon propos
liminaire qui et comment finalement
gérer
un réseau aujourd'hui dual concédé dons
concédés à l'échéance de la fin des
concessions pour les raisons
d'aménagement du territoire dans un
contexte de ressources qui sur le plan
budgétaire sont assez rares sur la
première ce premier sujet à l'époque
rappelez vous on avait une loi mobilité
pour laquelle il manquait 500 millions
par an de financements et l'oncle idée
que j'avais porté et qui avait été
travaillé était la suivante c'était de
se dire que pour financer ces 500
millions d'euros par an il était
possible d'annoncer le retour des
concessions autoroutières dans le giron
de l'état à échéance de celle ci c'est
entre 2031 et 2036 pour respecter la
lettre et l'esprit des contrats et sur
la basse la base pardon des recettes
futures perçues par l'état a pris en
compte d'ailleurs la dimension de
robinets qui on me savais baisse la
capacité de percevoir du péage sur la
base de ces recettes futures à horizon
2030 et un des mes 36 de lever de la
dette pour financer ces 100 500 millions
d'euros par an alors à l'époque
évidemment ça avait un défaut c'est que
ça endettés notre pays pour se faire à
des conditions d'ailleurs qu'ils
n'étaient était plutôt plutôt bonne un
peu plus que le taux d'endettement
d'état mais qui était quand même
supérieur
cette solution n'a pas prospéré il a été
choisi un bouquet de ressources fiscales
pour financer la trajectoire de la
mobilité notamment la contribution sur
sur l'aérien deuxième sujet c'est le
sujet que j'ai évoquées précédemment
c'était le sujet de la gestion dans le
futur donc moi je ne renie rien de mon
raisonnement de ma réflexion politique
sur le sur ce sujet je pense que la
deuxième partie de marc valide
la première est de fait écartée puisque
la loi mobilité a été financé sur le
rôle de chacun
la rt enfin l'état et la rt peut-être
rappeler les fonctions de chacun nous au
ministère des transports nous nous
occupons du contrôle opérationnel
s'assurer que les opérations ce réseau
concédé non concédées sont faites en
toute sécurité évidemment s'assurer de
de la com des commodités pour les
usagers et on est un sujet on a eu un
sujet extrêmement concret avec les
routiers dans les premiers jours de la
crise ducobu qui comme vous le savez on
trouvait à la fois ce réseau concédé et
nos procédés d'étoilés de fermer des
sanitaires non disponibles des points de
restauration qui n'était
plus à ce moment-là à leur disposition
et nous avons fait un travail
d'ailleurs sur le réseau public comme
sur le réseau concédé de vérification de
contrôle d'incitation les choses en plus
entre landes au bout de quelques jours
mais ça a été un travail
particulièrement précis intense des
agents du ministère des transports
notamment des dires il ya évidemment
l'ensemble des sujets environnementaux
et par exemple ce que ce qu'a permis ou
qu'on perd mille les différents
protocoles successifs et notamment ceux
de 2015 c'est d'avoir au sein des
contrats qui ont fait l'objet d'avenants
la mise en oeuvre de différentes mesures
environnementales qui sont venus poser
des des opérations pour la biodiversité
pour les différents et différentes
mesures du type protection des zones
humides qui ont permis de faire avancer
les choses et ça c'est du ressort du
médecin les transports que de vérifier
que toutes ces opérations là se font
évidemment de la meilleure des façons à
bercy appartient finalement le contrôle
économique et financier est alerte et
revient ce rôle de régulateur important
mais je crois que chacun doit être dans
son rôle parce qu'y compris sur
l'analyse des opportunités politiques
développement de thé hôtels infra c'est
bien du ressort du politique est donc
sous le contrôle du parlement de ceux
qui sont en charge de l'exécutif au nom
de la nation de se prononcer je crois
que madame ben on avait eu des propos
très précises sur ce sujet je les
reprends évidemment à mon compte
la troisième question que vous posez
c'est la question sur finalement quel
peut être le modèle d'après doit-on
aller au bout des concessions ou pas
j'ai essayé déboucher quelques quelques
pistes en disant qu'on pouvait en
quelque sorte fossilisés ces contrats ou
alors utiliser le modèle post 2015 pour
faire des investissements qui à mon avis
sont utiles et y compris re questionner
ces contrats en lien avec la rt pour
voir que les investissements étaient
inscrits parmi ceux ci
quels sont ceux qui font encore sans ce
combat et je pense que là il ya matière
avec les autoroutiers avec lesquels nous
devons avoir une relation ouverte et
exigeante
il ya matière à finalement retrouver
peut-être un peu de ressources
financières de capacité d'investissement
pour faire des investissements utiles à
la collectivité sur les modèles futurs
moi je vais reprendre encore une fois
finalement ici dans ce débat des
propositions qui sont faites par
d'autres y compris des députés qui
défendent des modèles intéressants
mon point de vue qui disent finalement
après les concessions que celles ci
soient que le réseau soit gérée par
l'état en direct où qu'ils soient
concédées ou délégués en tout ou partie
il faudrait peut-être envisager
justement pour que ce soit acceptable
par l'usagé d'avoir des concessions
multimodal autrement dit que finalement
le péage que vous payez servent à
financer par exemple des lignes à grande
vitesse ou des petites lignes
ferroviaires possiblement à une échelle
régionalisés ce sont des propositions
qui existe dans le débat politique que
je trouve intéressante lequel évidemment
les choses doivent être approfondis mais
qui permettent peut-être d'envisager au
delà des de l'échéance de 2030 est un
ennemi 36 ce que peuvent d'être les
concessions les concessions au delà de
leurs échéances
il ya aussi d'autres façons si nous
allions vers finalement une délégation
et si les opérateurs privés restent et
ceux qui géraient opérationnellement les
concessions est à la fois le modèle
concessive tel qu'on le connaît avec les
contrats que vous connaissez bien
et puis il ya d'autres façon de réguler
et économiquement les aéroports ou
d'autres ouvrages d'art sont régulés
avec des contrat de régulation
économique avec des clauses de revoyure
tous les trois quatre ou cinq ans et je
pense que tout ça doit être expertisée
de façon assez fine mais qu'en tout état
de cause des clauses de revoyure à
échéances régulières pour répondre à
votre question monsieur le rapporteur me
paraissent être une des conditions de
l'acceptabilité d'un meilleur contrôle
financier en lien avec les régulateurs
pour ne pas voir courir sur des périodes
très longues
est ce qu'on parle quand même de
plusieurs dizaines d'années des lois
tarifaire qui qui s'imposaient c'est
normal c'est contractuel mais qui on le
voit bien à échéance réguler régulière
viennent perturber perturber le débat
public est quelque part jeter l'opprobre
sur les uns et sur les autres qui
évidemment du point de vue de la
démocratie on dénomme n'est pas
souhaitable
merci monsieur le ministre de ses
réponses donc le rapporteur reviendra
sans doute un petit peu plus tard dans
notre audition je vais donner la parole
à eric bocquet ensuite ce sera monsieur
jacques 1ere parole oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur ministre merci de
vos propos là je voulais moi aussi
démarré sur la référence qu'elle fait
naître en rapporteur votre position
l'été 19 sur cette idée de
créer une société anonyme à capitaux
100% publics qui serait chargée
d'exploiter les autoroutes pour le
compte de l'état à la fin des
concessions dont vous venez de rappeler
que vous ne reveniez pas à ses idées je
vous en félicite
je la partage complètement
malheureusement vous nous dites que
cette solution n'a pas prospéré
nous avons auditionné madame madame
borne à sa manière je pense pas qu'elle
était sur cette ligne là enfin bon donc
j'aimerais savoir s'il y a aussi deux
gouvernements ont peut-être pas une
doctrine sur le sujet mais au moins une
orientation voir des réflexions sur
l'avenir de ces concessions voilà qu'est
ce que qu'est-ce qu'il en ait au sein de
l'ensemble de l'exécutif et la deuxième
question c'est sur le rapport qu'on a
souvent cité et danser dans nos travaux
celui de l'autorité de la concurrence de
septembre 2014
vilipendé par les concessionnaires
contestée par d'autres mais riche
d'informations à mon avis pour nous
parlementaires
quel est votre avis sur le les
conclusions de ce rapport
merci c'est le ministre merci monsieur
le président peut-être d'abord dire
qu'il n'ya pas encore de doctrine
établie sur l'avenir des concessions
parce que c'est un peu loin parce que je
crois que l'art est fait la réflexion
sur ce que nous pouvons faire maintenant
et encore pas tout à fait aboutie moi je
les change pour être très clair avec
vous la commission d'avoir des échanges
à plusieurs reprises avec les sociétés
concessionnaires pour bien comprendre la
problématique pour voir qu'ils étaient
leurs plans d'investissement pour voir
comprendre les contraintes à leur compte
et également essayé d'avoir une vision
le plus la plus objective possible et je
confirme qu'il n'a pas encore de
discussion interministérielle sur ce
sujet de l'avenir des autoroutes mais je
crois d'abord que c'est un objet
politique qui existe que les
propositions de nationalisation ont été
faites à plusieurs reprises je crois
qu'une loi est étudiée ici en cette
maison et que je ne doute pas que
l'horizon de 2022 ce sujet reviendra et
il me semble qu il serait de bon ton
notamment le parti politique auquel
j'appartiens fasse des propositions et
je ne veux pas que ça existera
sur le modèle pour préciser ce que
j'avais envisagé à l'époque c'était
d'avoir à la fois une société à capitaux
publics qui détient le patrimoine qui
éventuellement à côté à nîmes un fonds
d'infrastructure qui lui pourrait être
public et privé d'ailleurs et qui
déléguerait ou concéderait tout ou
partie de l'exploitation de
l'investissement de l'entretien d'un
certain nombre d'infrastructures avec
effectivement des conditions de contrôle
et de régulation que vous avez pu vous
avez pu citer j'ai pu dire que certains
députés défendent et des modèles encore
plus le maximum en tout cas plus
ambitieux peut-être moi je trouve que il
y à vraiment aujourd'hui matière les
idées sont sur la table il ya vraiment
matière à construire politiquement un
objet débattu évidemment sous le
contrôle du parlement parce que ça
intéresse lé territoire et je lis encore
une fois c'est très comment dirais-je
les infrastructures l'aménagement du
territoire conditionnent en quelque
sorte la capacité pour ces territoires
de rester connectés et donc leur
vitalité et donc leur attractivité et
tous les débats que nous avons
actuellement sur les lignes aériennes
2h30 4 etc
nous parlons toujours de la même chose
finalement et donc ces sujets sont
éminemment politique sur le rapport de
l'autorité de la concurrence
peut-être 2,2 points de réflexion le
premier c'est que je crois que ça a été
dit en commission
c'est vrai que l'appréciation et
l'évaluation de la suivante habilité en
faisant sur une année le ratio entre la
marge brute et le chiffre d'affaires
n'était pas très convaincant du point de
vue strictement de l'ingénierie
financière est le deuxième sujet
finalement sur ce qui est un risque
et comment ces risques se matérialisent
je crois que nous avons aujourd'hui une
situation économique qui permet un petit
peu l'illustré le risque de trafiquer
s'est exercée au moment de la crise de
2008 maintenant ce trafic poids lourds
qui est revenu au niveau de 2008
dix ans plus tard et il s'illustre
aujourd'hui avec des pertes qui sont
encore que des pertes estimées mais qui
sont importantes sur le risque travaux
par exemple on estime que la perte est
d'environ 200 à 300 millions d'euros
pour les sociétés concessionnaires
c'est tout à fait important est que la
perte sur coup par dont les surcoûts
et que pour la perte en recettes c'est
de l'ordre de deux milliards et demi
d'euros si on considère que la dynamique
de pertes se poursuit jusqu'à la fin de
l'année ce qui évidemment sont des
hypothèses qui se questionnent mais je
veux dire par là que il ya eu parfois un
débat politique qui consistait à dire
vous avez des risques vous avez une sur
rentabilité est établie face à des
risques qui ne se réalisent jamais on a
souvent caricaturé ce débat là comme ça
de fait il risque se réalise parfois et
quand il se réalise il se réalise
parfois durement et c'est le cas c'est
le cas actuellement sur la dernière
question que j'espère avoir noté que je
n'ai pas noté peut-être pouvez-vous me
le rappeler et ben voilà c'est fait il y
avait les réponses aux deux questions
sont bien là merci monsieur ministre
donc monsieur jacques 1 va vous poser
ses questions et ensuite j'aurai
monsieur foucher qui a demandé notre
collègue foucher qui a demandé la parole
olivier jacquin chez olivier dû en
principe évident merci vous m'entendez
oui très très bien bonjour un monsieur
mini séjour agréable de dialoguer avec
vous parce qu'en général on a des
réponses régionales obtenir une puisque
je vous avais écrit on après votre
domination communiste sur l'amendement
djebbari d'allah elle nous avait amené
quelques informations présentement mais
vous avez balayé le sujet en disant que
cette solution n'a pas été retenue
puisque on a trouvé d'autres solutions
de financement
vous ne répondez qu'à une partie de
l'intérêt de cette démarche qui visait
aussi et mon collègue au caylar appelé à
créer une société publique un contrôle
public très net sur le dispositif dans
le rapport dans la vingtaine
il avait fait une estimation très
prudente dans lequel il estimé qu'on
pouvait ramasser au moins 4 milliards
d'euros par an et le ministre que vous
êtes ne peut pas se désintéresser un tel
potentiel dans l'âme nous fait des
réponses de prospective très très large
moi je voudrais interroge sur cette
hypothèse de retrouver un modèle public
la ministre borne à évoquer l nouveau
contrat de concession plus resserré on
permettant notamment de d'intégrer des
principes pollueur payeur et des
autoroutes entre guillemets plus plus
verte
ce sera ma deuxième question des
autoroutes plus verte l'innovation
avance très très peu sur les autoroutes
à quelques expérimentations intéressante
de gare routière ans branchés sur des
voies réservées à le bus express
régulation tarifaire
on a eu une heure une audition
remarquable ce matin de 1 tmd mais sur
un pantin et qui nous a bien décliner
tout le champ des possibles des taux de
voile angers contre quoi pas chez nous
tout vient des blocages et même dans
l'album les différents amendements que
j'ai le poser pour faciliter la création
de voies réservées autres eh bien ça
bute est ce que c'est des problèmes le
dogme nécessaire de la sécurité mais il
ya vraiment des difficultés troisième
question alors là pour l'avenir ne
faut-il pas envisager de nouvelles
relations et s'il y avait des concepts
en privé de ne pas leur faire porter le
risque de trafic
on a des exemples en france quelques-uns
où le risque de trafic n'est pas pris en
compte par le privé et les coûts peuvent
baisser substantiellement j'ai eu des
études qui parlait de du coût de la
prise en compte par le privé du risque
trafic à 30 40 % du prix du de la
prestation du concédant puis dernière
question parce que là à faire de la
prospective on écarte vos
responsabilités actuelles on a découvert
pendant cette commission d' enquête
intéressante que les contrôles en cours
de concession et qui était prévu à la
régulière ne sont pas effectués dans une
édition de pause à tout le monde je suis
effaré vu l'insuffisance des contrôles
et
je ne parle pas les contrôles par an
c'est l'état des lieux qui était fait à
qui doit être fait de manière périodique
avant excusez-moi j'ai mal je reviens
sur mon propre agent termine on ne
parlait pas des contrôles mais de l'état
des lieux des concessions qui doit être
fait de manière périodique
je ne sais plus quelle était la date
c'était vraiment votre arrivée et même
avant le mandat de 2017
on n'a pas été effectuée quand dating
merci merci olivier d'avoir aussi
repréciser ta dernière question c'est le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président le sénateur
jacques 1 un plaisir partagé discuter
avec vous c'est toujours riche et du
coup je vais essayer d'être pratique et
peu prospective sur le sujet je vous ai
dit moi comme député j'ai eu et j'ai
souhaité évoquer voir porter un projet
de tour de concéder entre limoges et
poitiers
donc j'ai vu très concrètement comment
les choses se posait en termes
d'évaluation du trafic d'abord et donc
du risque trafic qui pourrait être
portée et dans les différents modèles
que j'ai proposé y avait des autoroutes
à péage où le risque de trafic est porté
par la collectivité en l'occurrence et
les modèles dits de tours de concéder où
le risque de trafic est porté par
l'opérateur privé ce que ce qui m'a
marqué et peut-être pour répondre à la
question de comment on améliore tout ça
c'est la difficulté d'abord à établir
des hypothèses de trafic partager
autrement dit quand vous parlez à la
dréal locales ou régionales quand vous
parlez à un opérateur qui vont produire
une note prospective
quand vous parlez au service d'une
collectivité comme la région vous n'avez
jamais les mêmes réponses et dans les
proportions parfois qu'ils varient du
simple au triple ce qui a un côté
parfois un peu inquiétant pour le dire
comme ça donc il ya probablement en
termes de compétences et par exemple
serema est une agence très grande
qualité
il ya probablement en termes de
compétences d'avoir des compétences à
garder dans l'état et puis peut-être se
doter de dalles gorille ou de faire
travailler notamment pour voir les
effets d'induction de trafic peut-être
se doter d'outils qui permettront de
beaucoup mieux évaluer le risque
le trafic est donc de faire possiblement
portée
derrière un risque trafic traduit en
théorie ou en taux de rentabilité
c'est le le premier objet peut-être que
là on a un travail de fond compétences
techniques à mettre en oeuvre et celles
issues de mon expertise profane députés
qui me fait penser sur le sujet des
objets de la transition écologique et
finalement d'où viennent les blocages je
pense qu'en partie des blocages ils
viennent aussi du contexte de relation
dite compliquées entre le concédant les
sociétés concessionnaires et on voit
bien qu'il ya peut-être une méfiance
réciproque et je crois qu'une des clés
c'est d'avoir une capacité à avoir des
échanges exigeant et ouvert chacun
défendant pour l'état à l'intérêt
général et pour les concessionnaires
leurs intérêts particuliers bien compris
et je pense que les contrats sont
toujours l'expression novembre qui l'a
dit ici mais la raison par la loi entre
les parties et personne n'est signé un
contrat si les intérêts des uns et des
autres ne sont pas ne sont pas bien
équilibré et donc du côté de l'état
évidemment l'intérêt général d'où
viennent les blocages peut être
effectivement de cette incapacité à
avoir des discussions apaisées sur
quelles sont dans les contrats
historiques les investissements qu'il
faut encore france quels sont les
investissements qui possiblement
aujourd'hui doivent être remis en
question quel et l'environnement où le
paysage fiscal on voit bien que les
choses baril et je pense qu'en toute
logique et un sur deux scènes hygiène
politique pendant dans l'ensemble vers
le secteur des transports au delà du
sujet que nous avons aujourd'hui nous
mettions une forme de stabilité fiscale
parce qu'on voit bien que les
investissements sont des investissements
temps long avec des cycles économiques
parfois compliqué et sujet aux aléas et
donc je pense que il ya une dimension de
confiance et de stabilité et de
prévisibilité pour l'ensemble des
acteurs dans cette petite affaire sur le
sujet de donc on me passe jeunes
arrivent elles à cette note
sur le sujet de l'état des lieux je
ferai une réponse du coup par écrit sur
ce sujet mais il me semble qu'en tout
cas du point de vue des contrôles de mes
services et donc de la sous-direction g
ca dont l'éminent sont derrière moi il
me semble que les choses sont bien
gérées en tout cas être toute ma
confiance et nous ferons passer monsieur
jacques à des réponses par écrit et sur
la dimension première sur laquelle vous
m'interrogez à savoir la pertinence du
modèle financier que j'avais pu exposer
à la station de maintenant d'abord dire
qu'effectivement en soi la capacité de
alors c'est un peu moins c'était 3
milliards et demi la capacité de de
lever annuel d'un tel mécanisme mais il
y avait 700 millions d'euros de frais
financiers mobilisés il y avait quand
même des il ya un coût à ce mécanisme
mais néanmoins sa pause de sujets plus
larges du financement des
infrastructures des grandes
infrastructures et en tant que tel
d'autres idées existent dans des vapeurs
dans le débat politique dans la dans les
différents organismes qui réfléchissent
à ce sujet donc moi je je je dissocie le
besoin de financement et la trajectoire
de la l'homme pour lequel cette
réflexion a été menée les différentes
opportunités de financer des
infrastructures qui vont bien au delà la
proposition que j'ai faite
et puis les diffusent des différentes
façons de réguler par contre à ces
différentes
infra à la fois noir construction de
leur vie madame borne à parler
effectivement de nouveaux contrats
concessif sur des modèles plus récents
et elle a raison j'ai parlé évidemment
du du modèle que on a pu évoquer puis
j'ai parlé de contrat de régulation
économique avec des temporalités plus
courte qui pourrait aussi être un modèle
qui s'applique mais encore une fois tout
ça devrait devrait être débattue devrait
être débattue sous contrôle du parlement
quand les choses se présenteront merci
monsieur le ministre olivier satisfaits
des réponses de monsieur le ministre où
tu as besoin de précisions oh mon
soutien je vous remercie
bon ben may merci olivier de cette
question alors de ses 200 beau
département de la vienne le sénateur
fouché
va vous interrogez vous poser quelques
questions tu as la parole merci merci
cher président monsieur le ministre je
retente parce que je considère vous êtes
un bon ministre
alors simplement vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le problème de poitiers limoges
il trouve que du ski lui à poitiers
qu'il a présidé le département et que si
les choses ne se sont pas fait c'est de
la faute des élus les élus qui étaient
incapables de se mettre d'accord entre
limousin et et viennent vous les trois
voire les quatre voies de l'autoroute
d'autorité parentale
on le sait des crédits ont été apportées
pour faire une une quatre voies qui
permettait d'alimenter les communes et
crédits ont été apportées par 2010 un
ministre pcf alors je me souviens plus
du nom mais mon collègue me dire deux
choses aux sports jean claude gayssot
jean claude gayssot
d'ailleurs claude gayssot il y avait des
crédits ensuite raf a ramené les crédits
et comme les élus ne s'entendait pas
entre eux pour savoir quel point fr bout
d'un moment quelques ep qu'est-ce que
peu d'états mercredi n'ont pas utilisé
les mêmes conclusions
rien ne s'est fait des études se sont
faites à tire larigot et un définitive
ça avance très doucement c'est une
quatre voies d'avant moins de trois mois
donc je veux dire là c'est vraiment la
faute des élus et pas de l'état mais la
faute des élus qui ont ils n'ont pas de
suisse anton le deuxième point je
voulais m'occuper de l'autre pas debout
d'évoquer avec vous on vous parlait des
nationalisations dans l'avenir pas tout
de suite
c'est vrai qu'en pensent eux on a vu la
gauche nationalisée on a vu la gauche
dénationaliser on l'a vu la droite en
fait un mélange un petit peu très
fréquent bon nationalisées mais c'est
très bien mais comment vous allez faire
financer tout ça
les et il faut des fonds ira défendre un
peu importants vous prendrez vous l'ayez
quelques talents prendrait les crédits
où ça coûte des fortunes des
nationalisations voudrais savoir comment
vous pourrez ensuite le troisième point
et je dois de me dire ça bon mais ça
c'est pas beau c'est votre ministère et
au mystère c'est une première de
l'équipement je comprends pas qu'en
france on pas des routes aussi cher on
est on est le pays en europe en pesant
les routes les plus chères extrêmement
cher et de systèmes du sable dans sa b2
des lieux et ça coûte très très cher
alors qu'on peut faire des routes aussi
efficace et moi je fais donc mon sujet
c'est en dehors de la route poitiers
limoges mon sujet c'est la
nationalisation je suis tout à fait
favorable
mais comme c'est à la question comment
on voit si tu es sur l'actuelle
situation financière
aujourd'hui mentionnant quelques ânes
etc puis d'ici là il ya des
gouvernements devront changer
s'attendent aujourd'hui encore comment
voilà comment le cas de manière vous
pouvez obtenir
et puis lancement merci alain donc la
parole va être ministre bond y at-il des
projets de nationalisation dans les
cartons du gouvernement actuel en tout
cas pas dans les miens monsieur le
président d'abord c'est le sénateur
fouché dire que sur poitiers limoges je
partage son avis sur le 10 ans us
politiques qui a empêché certains
projets de prospérer et peut être
revenir situer la nationalisation
d'abord c'est un coup de nationaliser et
les études ont été faites je crois que
fin 2010 9 serait écoutée 44 milliards
d'euros voire plus si on avait voulu
nationaliser regarde des contrats qui
sont en cours et
des recettes qui en sont attendus et
c'est tout le sujet autour du gel qui a
été pratiquée fin décembre 2014 qu'il a
fallu in fine est compensé par des
augmentations de tarifs entre 2019 et
2023 tout ça est maintenant bien quoi
bien connu et il est quelque part
heureux que dans un état de droit les
contrats s'applique s'applique de de
bonne foi et on voit bien que des
décisions d'un jour qui peuvent paraître
populaires sont souvent des coups en
dessous vendée coût pour les finances
publiques et donc in fine et pour le
contribuable qui sont qui sont
importants ou pour l'usager puisqu'en
l'occurrence est payé par l'usager
donc il n'y a pas de projet pour est
très claire de nationalisation des
autoroutes dans les cartons du
gouvernement actuel mais il ya une
réflexion sur l'après concession ou par
le coût par contre à ce patrimoine qui
est important et madame borne à 10 150
milliards d'euros revient dans le giron
de l'état et l'état à ce moment là à
nouveau le débat et le choix soit de
leur concéder soin de le gérer
directement
donc nous aurons ce débat là et j'ai
essayé dans une dent évoqué les grands
déterminant sur à la fois le modèle du
réseau que nous voulons pour nous mêmes
sur le financement du réseau sur les
capacités contributives de chacun et sur
évidemment le rôle des sociétés
concessionnaires qui évidemment ont des
compétences ont des moyens et ont prouvé
je crois qu'elle savait entretenir
concevoir exploiter les autoroutes pour
un taux moyen au kilomètre qui est me
semble-t-il est dans la moyenne
européenne mais nous en verrons à ce
sénateur fouché laisser ces éléments de
manière à clarifier le débat si besoin
en était merci monsieur le ministre est
à l'issue s'ils ont bien compris
le contrat qui lie le concessionnaire il
concédant la remise du bien est un bien
en plaine en état de fonctionnement et
donc voilà et là pour le coup il n'y a
pas de coût pour l'état donc il faudra à
ce moment-là réfléchir effectivement la
poursuite est prêt dans quelques années
je vais redonner la parole à notre
rapporteur vincent tu as la parole oui
monsieur le ministre je vous reparler un
tout petit peu des tarifs
parce que on a quand même un système
bien français de complexité avec 40000
tarifs différents pour lesquelles les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
remettre des propositions tout cas leurs
propositions
enfin en fin novembre début décembre et
axé sur la dgitm comme la dgccrf
finalement dispose d'assez peu de temps
pour vérifier tous ces tarifs qui
normalement devrait être relativement
simple puisque on applique normalement
ato ato moyens et comme il n'y a plus de
foisonnement donc on devrait avoir un
taux moyen partout mais il y a les
règles d'arrondi qui font que finalement
le système se complique
un petit peu j'ai compris que le système
d'arrondi en fête venait du fait qu' il
y avait encore des versements au cas des
paiements en liquide ce qui fait que
on arrondit surtout sur ses paiements en
liquide bon quels moyens il y à ty selon
vous pour améliorer ce système est ce
que il faut laisser plus de temps à
l'administration pour contrôler ça veut
dire qu'on demande aux sociétés
concessionnaires d'autos de donner leurs
propositions un mois avant
qu'est ce que il ya les moyens de
simplifier est ce que en supprimant les
paiements en liquide est ce que c'est
faisable de dire que quand on prend
l'autoroute il faut avoir une carte
bleue
est-ce que ce que ça simplifierait pas
largement le dispositif en tout cas il
nous semble que il y à des voies
d'amélioration dans ce domaine là qui
serait pas qui serait pas négligeable et
ma deuxième question c'est dans le cadre
des réflexions actuelles du gouvernement
est ce qu'il y a dans le en matière de
plan de relance des réflexions qui porte
sur sur les autoroutes et sur des
travaux puisque l'on sait très bien que
la plupart du temps c'est des travaux
qui sont effectués par des sociétés
françaises et que en termes d'emploi
c'est toujours intéressant de pouvoir
réaliser
sachant qu'il ya une critique qui a
quand même été fait et qui me paraît
assez justifiée c'est que on a enchaîné
plan de relance autoroutier plan
d'investissement autoroutier que ces
plans ne sont pas encore fini et est ce
que on relancera un nouveau plan avant
que les plans actuels ne soit achevé
merci vincent pour 7,2 question monsieur
le ministre ensuite vous serez une
question qui vous sont posées par
christine lagarde ou plusieurs questions
monsieur la parole monsieur le président
beaucoup de questions je connaisse pas
la fin d'abord dire que dans le cas du
pays à 2016 96 97 % des projets reste à
faire donc ça fait un volume tout à fait
considérable avant de parler de plan de
relance
il y aura un plan de relance il ya des
demandes territoriales qui sont qui sont
fête qui ne concerne pas en l'état des
projets autoroutiers et pour autant nous
avons des projets autoroutiers en cours
à la fois en cours d'instruction et puis
des projets autoroutiers qui soit c'est
ma thuôt qui deviennent matures comme le
projet toulouse castres pour lequel la
désignation des candidats se fera dans
les prochaines semaines et pour lequel
l'appel d'offres est prévue d'être
attribué en fin d'année nous avons à la
fois des projets autoroutiers et puis
les projets qui sont les fruits du pays
à 2016 qui ont vocation à être mises en
oeuvre sur la question des des paiements
et le maire général des nouvelles
technologies applicables aux à la
gestion d où l usage des autoroutes
il est évident que tout ce qui est
passage en free flow avec des
abonnements ou des paiements automatiser
la fin de mois sont des certainement des
objets qui intéresse beaucoup d'usagers
de même que la la carte t a permis de
beaucoup fut édifiée notamment pour les
voyageurs récurrents je sais pas si
interdire le paiement en monnaie d'abord
sera tout à fait acceptable
sur le plan constitutionnel ce plan du
droit commun il me semble que de toute
façon
de la même façon que de plus en plus de
voyageurs sont digitalisées où opèrent
des paiements à distance pour par
exemple réserver des trains on est de
moins en moins dans l'usagé de la
monnaie et en témoigne d'ailleurs la
réduction très forte des différents
points de passage aux différents péages
sur les règles et l'instruction des
services il n'y a pas à ma connaissance
est sous contrôle le sous-directeur qui
me l'a confirmé de problèmes sur
l'instruction en matière de délais
autrement dit avoir avoir un mois pour
instruire des concessions qui sont bien
connus pour lesquels les règles de
calcul sont établis parfois un peu
compliqué au titre du passé mais que
simplifiée avec le temps il n'y a pas de
problème de 2,2 délai est donc et donc
et donc je crois que je sais ça permet
de couper les différentes questions que
vous avez vous avez posé mais il ya
effectivement je crois une commande y
âge une nécessité d'avoir à la fois de
la stabilité dans ces environnements et
une capacité aussi de pouvoir aux
questions des règles à chaud à échéance
régulière vous avez vu beaucoup le
l'opportunité de débattre de ces clauses
de revoyure y compris ce que c'est
déterminant d'ingénierie financière qui
sont parfois complexes et je crois que
de toute façon une des roues un des
leviers efficaces dans la gestion
concédant qu c d et dans le traitement
administratif de cette relation
contractuelle c'est évidemment la
capacité à échéances régulières doré
interrogé un certain nombre d'hypothèses
sous-jacentes notamment les doigts
tarifaires et d'en simplifier les
déterminants financière notre collègue
christine lagarde va vous poser ces
questions je reste in une question mais
qui s'adresse du coup secrétaire d'état
chargé des transports puisque je vous
allez voir je veux en venir
le paya a permis des travaux de
rénovation voire réhabilitation pour
certains qui peuvent être assez
dispendieux car technique j'ai un
exemple en tête ou pour permettre
l'élargissement de l'autoroute ont fait
un viaduc en trois tronçons donc on voit
bien que c'est pas des travaux alléger
dans le même temps on a une ligne
ferroviaire qui elle ne fait l'objet
d'aucun travaux d'amélioration et donc
l'autoroute devient largement
compétitive en temps par rapport à la
ligne ferroviaire 1.1.1 au même endroit
là maintenant l'autoroute plus rapide
comment est-ce qu'on résout notre
objectif de stratégies nationales bien
carbone quand on sait que le transport
est un des principal émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre avec le logement voilà
enfin c'est pour dire que là on a donné
à la aux autoroutes un moyen de pouvoir
réaliser des investissements
là où d'autres secteurs du transport ne
les ont pas mais si quelqu'un très
intéressant que j'étais le roi
l'occasion d'échanger sur ce sujet avec
certains d'entre vous mais c'est le
sujet de la complémentarité
slash la concurrence entre les
différents modes de transport est
d'ailleurs bien souvent la façon très
différente de les financer ce qui est
sûr pour donner des faits c'est que 70 %
du budget du ministère est dédiée ou à
louer au mode ferroviaire
donc c'est du sur la stratégie nationale
bas carbone je crois que répondre
présent et d'ailleurs on a tenté c'est
en cours de régénérer les petites lignes
ferroviaires nous avons déjà signé le 20
février entre la pandémie mondiale et la
fin de la grève de contrat avec les
régions centre val de loire et et grant
est justement pour trouver des
mécanismes contractuels est un région
pour permettre de donner une seconde vie
en tout cas de poursuivre et pérenniser
ces lignes qui sont importantes pour
l'irrigation du territoire qui parlent
parfois effectivement sont concurrencés
par la route ça pose peut-être aussi la
question des des 110 km/heure finalement
ce que vous dites je reviens parce qu'en
fait j'ai envie d'en parler mais parce
qu'évidemment six liaisons rapides et
payantes ont l'intérêt de sécuriser les
déplacements ont un coût et finalement
ce qui s'y rapporte paye le temps et
paix et la sécurité
et et que si on est amenée à dégrader le
niveau de service de c2c ces axes pour
des raisons évidemment entendable sur le
plan écologique il faut peut être faire
un bilan coût bénéfices qu'ils soient
qu'ils sont un peu actualisées moi j'ai
pas de religion sur le sujet j'observe
que quand on eu le débat des 80 km heure
ce qui à mon sens cet exercice était
beaucoup un débat sur la sécurité
routière beaucoup un débat sur
l'écologie et beaucoup un débat sur les
libertés individuelles ce qui a rendu le
phénomène assez complexe à comprendre
mais que la cjce indécent d'y appliquer
au monal des autoroutes des autoroutes
ça pose plusieurs questions
d'abord 110 et la vitesse maximale comme
131 vitesse maximum actuellement et les
gens ne roule pas tout le temps à la
vitesse maximale euros la nuitée moyenne
qui est inférieur à ça quand vous avez
ces vitesses maximales vous à baisser la
vitesse moyenne est à ce moment là la
sensibilité aux prix en tout cas ce que
vous êtes prêts à payer pour le temps
peut varier autrement dit si vous roulez
en moyenne à 95 km 300 km h sur
l'autoroute et que vous payez x euros
pour un trajet alors que vous auriez
rouler sans qu'un à 115 à 120 km/heure
de moyenne dans le monde que nous vivons
actuellement
vous pouvez tenter de vous reporter sur
le réseau secondaire pour ne pas payer
auquel cas vous le coup gestione vous
passer à travers des villes possiblement
l'accidentalité augmente bref ça pose
d'autres questions et c'est ça un peu
que vous soulignez je crois dans votre
propos sur la complémentarité slash la
concurrence des modes y compris dans une
dimension de sécurité routière
d'aménagement du territoire etc sont des
sujets qui sont extrêmement complexes et
c'est aussi une des priorités du
ministère que je dirige que d'essayer de
se doter de ces outils de comparaison
qui sont des outils compliqué en termes
de gestion des flux en termes de
contribution environnementale et c'est
là dessus en tout cas que nous allons
essayer d'avancer ses prochains ces
prochains mois merci monsieur le
ministre vous aviez effectivement dans
votre propos liminaire tendu la perche
sur les 110 km heure la question de
notre collègue christine lagarde est
tombé à pic je crois
rapporteur et les sénateurs présents en
visio et dans la salle médicis pas
d'autres questions
mais monsieur le ministre nous allons
vous remercier ainsi que vos
collaborateurs pour votre participation
à cette audition
je remercie également les
administrateurs du sénat qui nous
assiste dans notre mission d'omissions
et je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour des auditions qui se
dérouleront le mercredi après midi n'ont
pas de mercredi après midi puisque notre
rapporteur préside la séance mais le
jeudi après midi
je vous remercie de votre participation
bonne fin de journée à tous et à toutes